[Music]
hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible
Q&A my name is Angela laking I'm glad
that you've tuned in today you are going
to be blessed I want you to get your
Bibles get a pen pencil whatever you
need to what to write down you're going
to have a wonderful time as we journey
through the word of God well today we
have three panelists that will be
answering your questions but before that
if you have questions I'm going to let
you know how to how to send in your
questions to us you can send it in by
going to Bible QA at
3abn.org
person you can go to 3abn uncore
official so that's the way to contact us
someone once said nothing less than a
whole Bible can make a whole Christian
and that's why we use the word of God
okay all right well let me introduce
this wonderful guest not they're not
guests they're our regular panelist
let's start with you honey my husband
the love of my life okay pastor John L
Kang welcome always good to be here
honey always good to have you in the
anchor spot thank you for taking the
time to do that I know you're a radio
person yeah it's good to see that you
are in the position you are today love
Bible Q&A it gives me a chance CU we
don't know what people are thinking and
this gives us an opportunity to find out
what are the questions out there that
you're sending in and we're praying that
God can use us to answer them clearly
thank you Pastor Daniel Marone welcome
thank you so much for the invitation
looking forward to answering your
questions all right do you enjoy bible
Q&A I do it's fun isn't it you dig into
the word of God all right
Daniel perin thank you I love what you
said about the whole Bible making a
whole Christian and I can't help but
point out we got four of them sitting
right here four Bibles so everything we
say appealing to the word of God that's
right and you enjoy bible Q&A don't you
yeah okay well we have let me tell you
how we're going to do this we have three
we have questions four questions and
we're going to answer them each one is
three minutes and we have one four
minute question but before we go on
let's ask uh Pastor Marone to open with
a word of prayer Father in Heaven Lord
what a privilege it is to get into your
word Lord You've preserved it for us to
bring us your comfort to bring us your
knowledge and bring us your salvation so
Lord we just thank you for your Holy
Spirit here and being with all of those
that are viewing now or listening we
pray this and thank you in Jesus name
amen amen amen thank you as sdas we've
always been known as people of the book
the word of God and right now we're
going to go to the book let's start with
you honey okay the first one question is
how does Jeremiah 6:16 apply to us today
well let me read Jeremiah 6:16 thank you
for the question and it reads as follows
thus says the Lord stand in the way and
see and ask for the Old Paths where the
good way is and walk in it then you will
find rest for your souls but they said
we will not walk in it that's a kind of
sad response the Lord said look for
those things that are the Old Paths
where the good way is and walk in that
well in a nutshel Jeremiah is referring
to when it says the Old Paths the things
that are tried and true you know we live
in a world today where so many new
things come to the Forefront you know
new inventions new ideas new theology or
transitioning from what has been proven
and tried that's why Jeremiah said stand
in the Old Paths the tried and true
paths the doctrines that have been
tested and retested and verified hold on
to those don't abandon those and he says
the reason is because that's the good
way and then when you find that which is
good as as the Apostle Paul says uh uh
try test everything uh the Apostle John
says test everything and see whether or
not it's lining up with God's word we
are told in the book of Timothy that all
scriptures given by inspiration of God
and is profitable for Doctrine for Repro
for correction for instruction in
righteousness so that's where the Old
Paths are we live in a world today where
being a Christian has become a popular
thing but standing on the tried and true
paths are not necessarily still popular
uh people come up with new Notions and
new ideas new gimmicks to gain access to
the hearts of people and churches are
popping up all over the place as in
America 501c3 tax exempt places where
people sometimes use that opportunity to
enrich themselves but the Prophet
Jeremiah is saying that God has given us
a Direction that's reliable for example
the reason why that's reliable is
because God's word doesn't change
because Jesus doesn't change Hebrews 13
and verse 8 Jesus Christ is the same
yesterday today and forever so the truth
of God's word is the same his
requirements remain the same his
Commandments remain the same these of
the tried and true paths where it may
differ now and this is something that
comes with modern times methods are
transferable but but not set in stone
I'll give you an example what I mean uh
we may do what our parents did but we do
not drive the same vehicles our parents
drive we don't use the same tools they
use tools change but make sure that
whatever you adopt that may be new still
stands the test of God's word
Deuteronomy 12: 30 a warning to the
Israelites take heed to yourselves that
you are not in snared to follow them
that's the Nations that do not serve God
after they are destroyed from before you
and that you do not inquire after their
gods saying how did these nations serve
their gods I also will do likewise
prefer the Old Paths amen and the Lord
thank you for that the Lord says I put
before you two roads right that's right
life and blessings right or death and
cursings yeah and he the old pths are
life and blessing amen choose life
choose life I would want I would want
life any day how about you all right
thank you all right Pastor Marone here
is your question my wife and I would
love to get some clear Bible
Understanding on prayer and
fasting any knowledgeable Bible verses
you can share would be very appreciated
this is from Lonnie and Francine in
Georgia well thank you Lonnie and
Francine and I could have gone two
different ways on this and I'm assuming
that you're wanting instruction on about
fasting and so forth so get your pencil
I've got several because the Bible does
talk a lot about fasting and it's
something that's you know it's
encouraging us to practice so and um I
want to give credit for Dr Joseph k and
a christe Hodson as far as some of the
thoughts that I've gained here but I
want to start with Daniel in Daniel
chapter 9 and veres 3 to 5 it says and I
set my face unto the Lord to seek by
prayer and fasting and supplications and
sackcloth and Ashes and I prayed unto
the Lord my God and made my confession
and said oh Lord the great and Dreadful
God keeping the Covenant and mercy to
them that love him and that keep his
Commandments we have sinned and have
committed iniquity and have done
wickedly and have rebelled even by
departing from thy precepts and thy
judgments he humbled himself in fasting
you know you're humbling yourself coming
to God expecting his Blessing so I'm
just going to throw out some uh
scriptures here we we want to as far as
preparing for fasting we want to prepare
we want to examine our motives that's in
Isaiah 58 3-7 we want to surrender our
life fully to Jesus and then that's in
Romans 121 and2 I want to ask God to
reveal our sins that's Psalms
1912 we want to confess our sins 1 John
1:9 this is in preparing for fasting we
want to seek forgiveness from those that
we have offended that's in Mark 1125
Luke 17 3 and 4 we want to make
restitution as the Holy Spirit leads us
that's in Matthew 5:23 to 26 I hope
you're right ask God to fill you with
the Holy Spirit that's Ephesians 5:18
and then you want to consult with a
physician of any type of a lengthy fast
that you're going to get into all right
and then what to do while you're fasting
I mentioned Daniel 9: 3 to5 there's acts
1423 and then we want to meditate on the
word of God in your fast and that's in
Psalm 1 1 and 2 and then Colossians 3:16
meditate on the attributes of God his
love his grace his wisdom and his
compassion and sovereignty Psalm 489 and
10 and then 103 1-13
and then you want to expect God's
blessing and that he was going to reveal
himself to you that's in Hebrews 11:6
and don't underestimate the spiritual
opposition that you're going to face
that's in Galan Galatians 5:16 And1 17
and then refuse to yield to your worldly
nature that's Romans 12 1 and2 and then
you want to exhibit a attitude of joy
you know you don't want to go around oh
I'm fasting you know that way that's in
Matthew 6177 and 18 and then Zechariah
8:19 thank you for the question again
blessings amen Jesus fasted how many 40
days and nights amen but he had the
father with him didn't amen so you're
not alone yeah thank you so much for
that okay Daniel perin this is a four
minute question so here goes is there a
time gap between Genesis 1 verse one and
1 verse2 this is from Sarah from New
Mexico
thank you Sarah for the question and
this is one of those new ideas that
Pastor L mang was just talking about
Genesis 1:1 you know it in the beginning
God created the heavens and the Earth
are a million years or plus inserted
here between that and the Earth was
without form and void and darkness was
on the face of the deep and the spirit
of God was hovering over the face of the
waters and then God speaks and begins
initiates a six day creation cycle to
assume that there is a gap here would be
a presupposition where we're going to
have to insert some time that is not
mentioned in any other place in the
scriptures and the modern development of
this Gap Theory doesn't just say there
was time there it also adds much much
more the modern Gap Theory goes
something like this God created the
heavens and the Earth in Genesis 1:1
animals plants man and everything and
then Lucifer fell and was cast down to
the Earth and everything devolved into
chaos and destruction
and then it was without form and void
and subsequently then God began wiped it
all out and started again with the six-
day creation so God started over again
now this new idea was not put forward
until 1840 with a Scottish Presbyterian
uh Scottish Minister named Thomas
Chalmer and it was put forward for one
reason and that is so that they could
hold on to this newly developing idea
that there were millions of years
recorded in the strata of the earth and
still still retain a belief in the Bible
so this idea tries to put together two
opposing ideas one Divine and one
satanic Evolution and creation and try
to hold them together this does not lift
Evolution up it drags the Bible down and
undercuts our faith in the scriptures
now if this Gap Theory only inserts a
little bit of time where where God
creates raw material and then waits for
a while before he forms and fills it
well there's not really any theological
differences necessarily there but that's
not what the Gap Theory tells us the Gap
Theory says this the fossil record where
where evolutionists get the millions of
years view the fossil record which is
the record of things dying year after
year after year and their their deaths
are preserved in the fossils all of that
happened before Adam and Eve were
created well if that happened before
Adam and Eve were created created then
it also happened before they sinned
which means that death would take place
before sin and if death takes place
before sin then death is not a
consequence of Sin Sin doesn't bring
death therefore Jesus death on the cross
for sin cannot cancel out the penalty of
death because death and sin are not
related this is an important distinction
and so it makes a huge difference what
you believe about where the fossils came
from it really a lot hinges on what you
believe about the flood because some Gap
theorists they actually insert more into
the Bible here proposing that there was
a first flood called Lucifer's flood
that wiped it all out and this is all
speculation you see when you get into
things that are not in the Bible you
have to make stuff up and add things and
so this idea of the Gap Theory you'll
find it in the the scoffield reference
Bible you'll find it in the new the
Newberry reference Bible and in D's
annotated reference Bible and a number
of other sources as well just to let you
know just because it's printed somewhere
does not mean it's true so we want to
take all our theories and let them be
tested by scripture so what does the
Bible say you find this in the law of
God spoken with his own voice Exodus
2011 for in six days the Lord God made
the heavens the earth and the Sea and
all that is in them and he rested on the
seventh day all right all of that in six
days and then he could look out look at
it and say this is very good no record
of death it's very good amen thank you
thank you for that and six days the Lord
created this Earth sometimes as humans
it's like wow six days we can't
comprehend that but he's God and we're
not right all right thank you honey John
L Kang it's your question here we go I
believe the Mosaic ceremonies were
nailed to the cross not the Ten
Commandments correct but Hebrews 1218 to
24 confuses me a bit verses 22 to 24 is
talking about Jesus the mediator of the
New Covenant but the lead in verses 18
to
21 seems to clearly be describing the
giving of the Ten Commandments this is
from a viewer in Tennessee okay let me
read them very quickly for you Hebrews
12: 18- 24 for you have not come to the
mountain that may be touched and that
burned with fire and to Blackness and
darkness and Tempest and the sound of a
trumpet and the voice of the words so
that those who heard it begged that
these words should not be spoken to them
anymore verse 20 for they could not
endure what was commanded and if so much
as a beast touches the mountain it shall
be stoned or shot with an arrow and so
terrifying was the sight that Moses said
I am exceedingly afraid and trembling
but you have come to the Mount Zion and
to the city of the Living God the
heavenly Jerusalem to an innumerable
company of angels to the general
assembly and Church of the firstborn who
was who are registered in heaven to God
the judge of all the spirit and the
spirits of just men made perfect to
Jesus Jus the mediator of a New Covenant
and to the blood of sprinkling that
speaks better things than that of Abel
going back you know I think that the
part that they're focusing on and this
is my assumption since it was not
brought out in the question so that
those who heard heard it beg that these
words should not be spoken to them again
you know the experience of The
Commandments being given to Moses the
people heard the thundering and it was a
frightful experience for them and then
Moses presented to them the Commandments
of the Lord
and so the Commandments of God as Paul
the Apostle talks about in Romans 7 they
thought their lives are just perfectly
fine until the Commandments as Paul says
the law of God revived and I died it
brought them to this frightful
understanding when we compare Our Lives
to the perfect law of God it causes us
to be filled with fear and consternation
and trembling and so it was not the law
of God that was the issue which was in
fact alluded to here it was the way that
it made them feel their reaction to it
and so as Moses was reminding them of
what God said to them the Bible talked
about they could not endure it that was
commanded and so this holy law of God is
something that brings us to the place
where the realization of God's
requirements are great and only can be
accomplished by the indwelling Christ
but make no mistake about it the New
Covenant does not remove the
Commandments of God it now enables us he
put his law Hebrews 10:16 he says this
is the Covenant Covenant that I will
make with them after those days says the
Lord I will put my laws into their minds
and in their hearts I will write them
meaning it's no longer on tables of
stone it's in our minds and it's in our
hearts and as in the Old Testament the
only way that we can live in harmony and
not be fearful of God's law is by the
indwelling power of God's holy spirit so
yes Hebrews was alluding to the law of
God
but do not allow that to make you
fearful Embrace God's law and he'll
enable you to live in harmony with it
that's right it's a moral law it's a
moral law exactly can't be changed amen
thank you so much all right Pastor
Marone this is a four minute
question here we go why is the holy
spirit elevated above God and
Jesus we can do evil against God and J
or Jesus but not the Holy Spirit why is
that this is from
Lawrence great question Lawrence and
we're speaking of the Holy Spirit here
let me just read a couple of scriptures
here that's alluding to what you're
saying there Luke 12:10 and whosoever
shall speak a word against the son of
man it shall be forgiven him but unto
him that blasphemeth against the Holy
Ghost it shall not be forgiven then
Matthew 1231 and 32 wherefore I say unto
you all manner of sin and blasphemy
shall be forgiven unto men but the
blasphemy against the Holy Ghost shall
not be forgiven unto men and whosoever
speaketh a word against the son of man
it shall be forgiven him but whosoever
speaketh against the Holy Ghost it shall
not be forgiven him neither in this
world neither in the world to come so
from these two verses it could sound
like the holy spirit is superior to
Jesus so that's a great question
Lawrence thank you for sending it in and
I'm sure others have actually had the
same question well the reason that Jesus
is saying this
it has to do with the jealousy of the
Pharisees causing them to accuse Jesus
of casting out demons with the power of
be elub or Satan and Jesus says in
Matthew 12:28 but if I cast out Devils
by the spirit of God so he's saying that
uh he's letting us know Jesus is letting
us know that he was doing this by the
holy spirit that he was casting them out
coming back at them so the Pharisees
were trying to attribute that the Holy
Spirit did to what the Holy Spirit did
to Satan
power so and Jesus calls that blasphemy
you know what God's holy spirit was
moving upon him to do causing that you
know causing it be thought of that it
was Satan doing it that was blasphemy so
the reason he's not able to be forgiven
uh is because that the Holy Spirit who
reveals in other words someone that's
not being able to be forgiven for the
holy spirit it's because the holy spirit
is the one that brings conviction to a
person so when we push that away then we
don't have any other source to help us
to uh get that conviction and then when
we deny the attribute or or attribute
the conviction to any other than the
Holy Spirit then we're blaspheming or
rejecting him or God so the holy ghost
or Holy Spirit isn't any higher in
Authority or rank each of the godhead
has a specific roles that they carry out
and they're all one in love and this
kind of love is hard for us to
comprehend but God is love they're all
love and the love things that God is
doing through the holy spirit so the
next time that you recognize that God's
speaking to you and it's usually through
a still Small Voice like he did Elijah
in First Kings
19:12 we we want to say yes to his
prompting and Jesus is always saying
today is the day of salvation he says
Harden not your heart when he's saying
Harden not your heart heans meaning you
know the Holy Spirit keeps speaking but
when we Harden our heart we just don't
hear it anymore we listen don't listen
to him so the reason it's blasphemy
against the Holy Ghost can't be forgiven
is that when we keep on rejecting we
cease to hear him or recognize and it's
actually God's love love to us that he
is doing that he knows the end result of
whatever we're doing or not doing 1 John
1:9 says if we confess our sins then
he's faithful and just to forgive us of
our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness so if the holy spirit's
the one that brings the conviction that
something is sin and we keep rejecting
that pretty soon we don't think of it as
Sin
anymore and if we don't think of it as
Sin anymore why do we need to confess it
if that makes any sense to you that's
what I discovered here in God's word and
so we don't want to reject the spirit of
God we want to listen to him thank you
again forence for the question amen and
thank you so much Pastor and truly the
spirit will lead us and guide us into
what all truth amen that's right he will
guide us into all truth beautiful that's
from John
16:13 okay Daniel parin here is your
question what does it mean that Satan
transforms himself into an angel of
Light which angel of Light what was this
an isolated event or does he still do it
this is from Ben in maius all right Ben
the statement that uh Satan transforms
himself into an angel of Light in 2
Corinthians
11:14 means that Satan is Crafty and
subtle and he is hard to notice which
are with our natural eyes and our
natural way of thinking something that
looks glorious or appears marvelous may
be demonic something that heals could be
evil and something that gives words of
apparent wisdom could be subtle lies
just like Eve looked at a serpent looked
at fruit and was deceived so which Angel
well the only Angels mentioned in the
Bible are Gabriel and Michael and
Michael is Jesus humans aren't told the
names of any other Angels so if an angel
so it's not specific angels that Satan
is impersonating because that wouldn't
deceive us we don't know those angels
and he's not going to deceive God Satan
transforms himself into an angel of
Light by appearing to do what angels of
light are expected to do Holy Angels do
not always appear as bright beings
remember Abraham and lot Angels Came to
them in the form of humans in Hebrews
13:2 which says that people have
entertained angels uh thinking that
they're just helping out a stranger in
human form in other words uh Satan can
appear as an angel of Light by appearing
as a wise counselor a helping hand a
miracle worker a Godly messenger with a
Word of Wisdom or a stranger in need
you've heard the stories I turned around
to see who helped me and know no one was
there it must have been an angel well
Satan can do that he can gain our trust
and share words of wisdom and a message
does Satan do it today remember Satan is
subtle that's right and so for example
he does this work with healing practices
that suppress the symptoms of a disease
without actually dealing with the cause
of the disease leading us to believe
that we're healed but we can go on
living with the same intemperate habits
that cause the disease in the first
place this is what Satan wants us to
believe you can have healing without
change and the truest healing is
salvation amen that's and so we look and
we say the Lord healed me but we haven't
had to change our life we just had some
practice that suppressed the the symptom
of it Satan wants us to think that way
and so here's the lesson from this text
don't trust a vision don't trust a
supernatural visitor don't trust a
glorious being just because they're
Supernatural don't trust any common
person just because they're a good
person and they help me don't trust a
healing practice or a miracle just
because it heals you Satan can do that
just because it works don't love healing
and don't love your life so much that
you would forget to test everything by
the principles of God's word in other
words you have to know God's word make
it a priority every day so whatever
comes your direction you can test it by
the word of God amen amen well said wow
the B we have to test it by the word of
God here a little there a little Isaiah
28:10 and wow we're living in the last
days when where deception is great and
it's getting greater and greater because
we know Satan is going to appear one day
as an angel of Light so be sure to study
the word of God well maybe you've just
tuned in and you said I have a question
I I I would like to send in well you can
email your questions right now to Bible
QA
3abn.org
person well you can go to 3abn uncore
official all right thank you guys doing
a great job all right my honey in front
of me Pastor John yes honey here is your
question it's a short one this is from
Mario sent an email in can you
explain please explain John 20 verse 21
to 23 sure thank you Mario let me read
that passage for you so Jesus said to
them again peace to you as the father
has sent me I also send you he's talking
to his
disciples and when he had said this he
breathed on them and said to them
receive the Holy Spirit now this is
before the day of Pentecost so when
people think that they did not receive
the Holy Spirit till the day of
Pentecost that's not true that was
before what they received on the day of
Pentecost was the power to transform
their language from Galilean to the
languages of the people around the world
to carry the gospel to the entire world
they received the power on that
particular day and then he says in verse
23 I think this is the part where you
want the explanation if you forgive the
sins of any they are forgiven them if
you retain the sins of any they are
retained Jesus was establishing in the
minds of his disciples to become his
Apostles this ecclesiastical Authority
that the church still maintains today
you know I'm a pastor and we have an
ecclesiastical structure in our church
we have accountability at every level we
have a church board we have a conference
committee we have ministerial director
who now I have a pastor I have people
that I'm their pastor but I have a
pastor he's the pastor of all the
pastors and the pastor of all the
pastors has to answer to the Secretary
of the conference who answers to the
president of the conference who answers
to the leadership of the Union who
answers to the leadership of the
division who answers to the leadership
of the General Conference the Lord was
establishing ecclesiastical Authority in
other words he says whatever you do
heaven would recognize it if you don't
recognize it heaven will not recognize
it he was giving them Authority not to
ignore God's word but to practice
everything accordingly and we find in
Ephesians chapter 2 this very
ecclesiastical Authority established he
says in in Ephesians 21:19 now therefore
you are no longer strangers and
foreigners but fellow citizens with the
Saints and members of the household of
God verse 20 having been built on the
foundation of the Apostles and Prophets
Jesus Christ himself being the Chief
Cornerstone so I'm an un Under Shepherd
Jesus is the chief Shepherd in whom the
whole building being fitted together
grows into a holy Temple in the Lord so
when Paul says do you not know that you
are the temple of God he's speaking of
the church collectively as well as us
individually then he says in verse 22 in
whom you also are being built together
for a Dwelling Place of God in the
spirit so what John is simply recording
is the
ecclesiastical appointment that the Lord
is now giving to his disciples he says
I'm giving you Authority in Luke 10: 16
to18 I'm giving you authority over
serpents and scorpions and over all the
power of the enemy and nothing by any
means will hurt you and even when he
spoke to Peter and the apostles he says
what you bind on Earth will be bound in
heaven what you loose on Earth will be
loosed in heaven this is simply Jesus
communicating ecclesiastical Divine
Authority amen that's right we have a
checkpoint in every level in in the
Advent which is why independent churches
that have nobody to answer to are
dangerous say that again why independent
churches where the pastor answers to no
one is
dangerous wow is that true that's what I
love about the structure of this
worldwide Adventist Church it's
beautiful so we don't have a my way or
the highway attitude no
no amen thank you for that okay pastor
marconei this is a short question what
is the main lesson of neem
Maya well thank you for that short
question here's a three minute answer
yeah uh I'll say the main idea is in uh
chapter 4 verse 6 of Nehemiah it says
for the people worked with all their
heart so I look at the book of Nehemiah
when we're doing the work of God or the
work of God in our own lives we want to
do it with all our heart not hold
anything back that's the main lesson so
I would but I'm going to since I get
three minutes here I I'll break it down
to seven other lessons here to break
that same main one down in the seven so
we want to identify the need here in F
uh Nehemiah 1: 2 and 3 here's what it
says that hanani one of my brethren came
he and certain men of Judah and I asked
them concerning the Jews that had
escaped which were left of the Captivity
con uh concerning Jerusalem and they
said to me the remnant are left of
captivity there in the province are in
great affliction and reproach the wall
of Jerusalem also is broken down and the
gates thereof are burned with fire so he
recognized there's a need there and then
we want to plan carefully that's another
lesson we can learn here from the book
of Nehemiah in chapter 2: 7 and 8
moreover I said unto the king if it
please the king let letters be given me
to the governors beyond the river that
they may convey me till I come into
Judah and so then he got the uh
permission from the different ones along
his way and then the materials and so
forth
and then we want to plan carefully um
that's another one in uh well I already
said that one in dealing with opposition
and frustration that's in chapter 2
verse 19 4 verse 7 and 8 and then 62
these are things you might be writing
down and they were made fun of and
laughed at and ridiculed and taunted so
there's going to be opposition sometimes
when you're working for God and then you
want to work as a team here in Nehemiah
31:4 and then 11:2 it says in verse one
then Elias the high priest rose up with
his Brethren the priests and they build
the Sheep gate they were they Sanctified
it and they set up doors of it even unto
the Tower of Mia they were they
Sanctified it and then in verse two and
next to him so these guys were doing
this work and the next to him they build
the men of Jericho and next to them
build zakor the son of ery so they were
working as a team when we work as a team
we can accomplish a lot for the Lord and
then leading through service Nehemiah
5:116 yay also I continued in the work
of this wall neither brought me any land
and all my servants were gathered
thither in the work so he was a servant
leader Nehemiah he did it also he didn't
just say you guys do it and then he want
we want to show faith and commitment
that's something if we find in Nehemiah
88:9 and then 10 and we will not forsake
the house of our God that was in
Nehemiah 6 and I sent Messengers unto
them saying I'm doing a great work so
that I cannot come down why should the
work cease whilst I leave it and come
down to you and and then persevering
that's another thing we going to learn
perseverance and Main maintaining Focus
Nehemiah 13 and this chapter brings out
some of the final reforms of Nehemiah
after reading the book of the law and
seeing they weren't supposed to mingle
with the Heathen they separated
themselves then there was Sabbath reform
he brings out and not buying and selling
on the Sabbath tithe reform marriage
reform those are all things we can learn
from Nehemiah the lesson thank you
question wow wow you said it not much
time but Nehemiah is an amazing book is
that the one that he said has a mind had
a mind to work to work yes and they
built boy and there was always a devil
sambalat I think that's the one let's
try to distract them right yeah thank
you so much all right Daniel
pin here is your question it says here
it's a little lengthy okay after all the
arguments have been debunked about the
law being abolished and only for the
Jews now the anti
tyian have come up with two other verses
to show that the law is finished and
there are no more prophets since John
the Baptist namely Matthew 1113 and Luke
16:16 what do you say can you explain
these verses this is from Maurice in
berai all right Maurice thank you and
and just as a reminder what I say
doesn't matter what the word of God says
matters here and an antinomian for those
of you who are wondering means someone
who is against the law or says that the
law of God has been done away with and
these two texts both have the same
explanation they say basically the same
thing and I'm just going to read Matthew
11:13 that says for all the prophets and
the law prophesied until John in other
words the Assumption here that they
continued until John and then they
stopped and were done away with now the
law and the prophets refers to the whole
Old Testament what we call the Old
Testament the law and the prophets I
have to look at the context of Matthew
11 where Jesus has just declared John
the Baptist to be the greatest of the
prophets and what made him the greatest
it was because he had the privilege of
pointing to Jesus in person saying this
is the Lamb of God right now until John
prophesied until John the law and
Prophets doesn't in any sense indicate
that the Old Testament scriptures would
pass away what it means is that they
were leading up to their Crescendo until
JN that Crescendo is the Declaration of
Jesus making clear what the scriptures
had been saying all along because until
the time of John the Baptist the law and
the prophets were the only uh witness
declaring Jesus pointing to Jesus but
they were pointing to him to come they
weren't pointing to him in the flesh as
a person all there was was this written
record the the the documents and the
Scrolls pointing to Jesus that is until
John the Baptist came and now John the
Baptist could say here he is the one who
is spoken of this is the one we've been
anticipating all the time the Old
Testament the law and the prophets spoke
in symbols and and prophecies about
Jesus and John said the symbolism is now
fulfilled the prophecies are fulfilled
here and how did John do that how did he
point to Jesus as the Fulfillment of
those symbols he said Jesus is the Lamb
of God that's right now Jesus himself
never belittled the scriptures and nor
do any of the other New Testament
writers instead Jesus instructs us that
we should study to study them listen to
Jesus in Matthew 5:17 in The Sermon on
the Mount think here whether or not it
sounds like Jesus is saying the Old
Testament has been done away with he
sayso not think that I came to destroy
the law or the prophets I did not come
to destroy but to fulfill them and in
the following verses he says we need to
obey the law and the prophets even after
Jesus death and Resurrection he gives a
Bible study in Luke 24 to The Travelers
on the way way to Emmas and he uses the
law and the prophets if they stopped at
John Jesus couldn't have used them after
his death and Resurrection so the gospel
message everything about Jesus does not
oppose what has been written it
illustrates it embodies it enriches it
illuminates it when God gives us more
light he never does it by extinguishing
the light that he already gave it just
grows brighter so we can see more
clearly the one clear message of the
scriptures Jesus Christ is our savior
amen and the law who's against the law
Satan Revelation 12:17 what does it say
and the dragon Satan was enraged with
the woman the church went to make war
with the rest of her Offspring who do
what keep the Commandments of God so we
know when it comes to the law of God
Satan is angry about it okay remember
that all right thank you so much okay
pastor John are you ready this is your
last question and it's a four minute
question okay it's a power packed one
and we know you've been studying this
for a while here we go how do you know
if you are walking in the spirit or In
the Flesh let me start with Galatians
5:6
and we'll show you the comparison the
difference but let me just start with
Galatians 5:116 I say then walk in the
spirit and you shall not fulfill the
lust of the flesh you know the Apostle
Paul recognized that there was a dual
battle going on he said with my mind I
serve the law of God with my flesh the
law of sin and when he says the law of
sin he's not talking about the law of
God he talked about he says I see the
law of God in my mind but there's
another law in my members bringing me
into captivity to the law of sin and
death which he says is in my members
what he was talking about was when we
live according to our human nature our
natural inclinations that's Walking In
the Flesh this Fallen nature that we
receive from Adam Romans 5:12 that that
that sin that came into the world and
and death was passed upon all men when
we walk into our natural desires our
natural inclinations we are walking in
the flesh in other words God says do
this we say no I'm going to do that
that's walking In the Flesh when we walk
in carnal ways that's walking in the
flesh but walking in the spirit and Paul
describes in Galatians 5: 19 to 21 what
walking in the flesh is like he said
now the works of the flesh are evident
which are adultery fornication
uncleanness lewdness idolatry sorcery
hatred contentions jealousies outbursts
of wraths selfish Ambitions dissensions
heresies Envy murder drun drunkness
revelries take a breath and the like of
which I tell you beforehand just as I
told you in time past that those who
practice such things will not inherit
the kingdom of God let me insert
something that's not a part of the
question he's not saying that if you've
done those things you cannot inherit the
Kingdom of Heaven he says if you
practice those things if if this becomes
a part of your practice you are walking
in the flesh this is how I'm living my
life I'm walking in that natural
carnal uh uh destructive way of living
I'm walking in that lower nature Walking
In the Flesh and that's what that means
so if you're not walking that way then
there's only one other way that you walk
and Paul made it clear in Galatians uh
in Romans 8 verse1 and
2 there is therefore now no condemnation
to those who are in Christ Jesus who do
not walk according to the flesh but
according to the spirit for the law of
the Spirit of life in Christ Jesus has
made me free from the law of sin and
death once again I reiterate the law of
sin and death are are not the
Commandment it's not the Commandments of
God it's the Fallen broken human nature
this corrupt nature given to us by Adam
1 Corinthians 15:22 as in Adam all die
even so in Christ all shall be made
alive so when you're walking in the
flesh you're walking in that broken
nature that is against God where the
Bible says in Romans 8 ver5 those who
live according to the flesh set their
minds on the things of the flesh but
those who live according to the spirit
the things of the spirit so now how do
you know you're walking in the spirit
Galatians 5:22 and 23 this is the spirit
you exude but the fruit of the spirit is
love joy peace longsuffering kindness
goodness faithfulness gentleness
self-control and I love this against
such there is no law meaning you can't
be too lawful you can't be too kind you
can't be too to love and you'll never go
to jail for being the person that loves
people too much what's your sentence you
are too kind you get 5 years in jail
against such there is no law the Bible
says so when you think about that this
is a simple comparison how do you know
that you and one of the other when you
are fulfilling the fruit of the spirit
you are walking in the spirit when you
are fulfilling the works of the flesh
Galatians 5:1 19-21 you are walking in
the flesh Christ Jesus can give you
power to walk in the spirit amen well
said and the key word is practice
practice you a sermon called pra the
practi the practice check it out on
YouTube the practice the practice yeah
we don't want to practice evil do we
thank you for that push yeah all right
thank you okay pastor Marcone let's go
right into your question can you please
explain Matthew 6
19-21 I'm curious about the
treasures we are to store up in heaven
I know in the Old Testament there is a
scripture that pertains to God's people
as a pecul treasure is it people we are
to store in heaven this is from
Jeff great question Jeff thank you for
sending that in let's read that yeah uh
verse 19 to 21 in Matthew 6 it says lay
not up for yourselves Treasures upon
Earth where moth and rust doth corrupt
and where thieves break through and Ste
steal but lay up for yourselves
Treasures in Heaven where neither moth
nor rust doth corrupt and where thieves
do not break through nor steal for where
your treasure is there your heart will
be also well let's go to uh Luke 12
where Jesus launches into a parable when
a man approached him asking for Jesus to
get his brother who hadn't shared his
inheritance to share with him in verse
15 of Luke 12 Jesus says to beware of
covetous
for a man's life consisteth not in the
abundance of the thing which he
possesses and then we go to verse 16 to
21 he emphasizes in those verses that uh
if we're laying up Treasures in Heaven
let let me go there Matthew chapter I
mean Luke 12 and verse 16 to 21 it says
and he spake a parable unto them saying
the ground of a certain rich man brought
forth plentifully and he thought within
himself saying what shall I do because I
have no room where to bestow my fruits
and he said this will I do I'll pull
down my barns build greater and there
will I bestow all my fruits and my goods
and I'll say to my soul soul thou Hast
much Goods laid up for many years take
thine ease eat drink and be mared maybe
wondered where that came from there it
is eat drink and be mared and God said
unto him thou fool this night thy Soul
shall be required of thee then whose
shall those things be which thou Hast
provided
so in uh he's talking about fools there
when you're just accumulating all these
things you know he has two great
Commandments you know love God with all
our heart soul and mind and then our
neighbor our man fellow man as ourselves
so I think you're correct Jeff it says
putting others before ourselves thinking
about others with whatever the Lord has
blessed you with rather than just
yourself and in verse 31 of Luke there
it says but rather seek ye the kingdom
of God and all these things shall be
added unto you so we don't have to worry
about our own selves so seeking the
kingdom of God which is based on
selflessness would be laying up our
Treasures in Heaven our characters are
the only commodity that we can take from
this Earth to Heaven again thank you
Jeff that's right I like that only our
characters nothing we have will take
with us to the kingdom okay thank you
for that all right Daniel perin why were
job's friends miserable comfort
job's miserable comforting friends job
had lost his wealth and his health and
his kids and his wife's support and it
appeared that he hadd lost support from
God and then come along as friends and
they sit with him for seven days and
then they debate and argue with him for
the rest of the book for three rounds of
speeches and in job 16 1-5 it says then
job answered and said I have heard many
such things miserable comforters are you
all and then he tells us why in the next
three verses shall words of wind have an
end all right a bunch of air and he's
responding to elaz one of his friends in
the previous chapter who said that job
was filled with empty knowledge and
words of wind imagine comforting
somebody like that you big windbag how
comforting job continues I also could
speak as you do if your soul were in my
soul's place I could Heap up words
against you and shake my head at you but
I would strengthen you with my mouth and
the comfort of my lips would relieve
your grief in other words he says you're
not helping me you're just attacking me
in job 13 he had said this he said oh
that you would be silent hold your peace
with me and let me speak in other words
he says stop talking I don't want to
hear anymore of what you're saying and
they kept on going for like 15 more
chapters so here's a basic summary Z
I'll just give you some some excerpt
here zofar in 11:6 said that job
deserved worse punishment than he was
getting oh no comforting bildad said
18:2 how long till you put an end to
words gain understanding and afterward
we will speak in other words shut up job
go learn a few things and then we'll
talk elifaz said in 22:5 that job's
iniquity was Without End eliu told job
in
34:36 that he talked like a wicked man
now to be honest there were some things
that job's friends here said that were
true they had some truth c in there but
you can mix it with things that were
wrong and you can give Truth at the
wrong time you see someone down in a pit
and you say I'm going to lecture you
about safety help the person out amen
and then later you can give him the
safety talk if you need to all of job's
friends and even job himself their spe a
little bit their speeches revolve around
one basic idea and it was a wrong idea
you will get paid back in this lifetime
for whatever you do with your behavior
and it's basically different shapes and
sizes of Wheels all rolling on this one
axle that you're going to get paid by
God in this lifetime for what happens
but they were all wrong about that job's
suffering was not a consequence of his
behavior instead Romans 12:15 we should
do this Rejoice with those who Rejoice
weep with those who weep amen amen I'm
so glad the Lord is merciful and patient
and kind and gracious with us amen well
we are going to take a short break and
when we come back we're going to have
some closing Thoughts by this wonderful
panel we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using using God's holy word to shed
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
Bible Q&A for answers from God's word I
hope you were blessed the way I was
blessed I always learned something from
this illustrious panel well we're going
to have a few closing thoughts we're
going to start with Daniel purin when
you're in the position of job's friends
don't say I Told You So Point people to
the love of Jesus that's what they need
in that moment there's other truths that
come later Point them to the loving
character and nature of Jesus well said
Pastor Dan I was thinking about that um
question about the holy spirit being
Superior I look at all of God is as one
he's all love and the three are one but
the holy spirit is the one who brings
the convictions to us into our hearts
and our minds and so Jesus is speaking
through the Holy Spirit when he says
come unto me all you that labor and are
heavy laden I'm going to give you rest
yes and that's his will for us today
amen Pastor John and Jeremiah when he
talked about the Old Paths this is
something that the churches are being
challenged with nowadays we get L us so
many people say they're doing so much
new stuff we're losing our identity yes
well no let me give you a couple of
words of encouragement first of all
Proverbs 3 verse 5 and six as a leader
don't lean on your own understanding
even as a leader don't lean on your own
understanding pray and ask God and then
you have a church board make decisions
that the church is supportive of and the
Bible says the reason why Proverbs 11:14
where there is no counsel the people
fail but in the multitude of counselors
there is safety if you make decisions
about anything new that's changing your
church make sure that you have support
of the church body and one person says
make a lot of talk about change but do
it slowly amen that's right thank you we
had a wonderful time ministering in the
word of God and my closing thought is
your word I have hidden in my heart that
I might not sin against you Psalm 11911
so have a blessed day in Jesus
[Music]